c'est une kermesse surréaliste organisée
par des dealers un barbecue avec merguez
gratuite un château gonflable une
piscine et un jeu de pêche aux canards
ont été installés pour fêter le 14
juillet dans la cité du docteur M ces
animations sauvages auraient été mises à
disposition par des trafiquants de
drogue dans plusieurs cités de Nice et
Cavaillon et selon le maire et l'air de
Cavaillon les dealers reprennent
possession des lieux ils agissent comme
des Robins des bois en redistribuant une
toute petite partie de l'argent du deal
pour gâter les habitants et ainsi
s'assurer leur silence mais alors la
fautaki et bien selon un membre du
Collectif Citoyen le chemin de l'école
en toute sécurité c'est la conséquence
de l'abandon de la cité par la
municipalité qui nous propose aucune
activité à ses habitants une enquête a
été ouverte et la mairie de Cavaillon a
déposé plainte contre X pour occupation
illégale de l'espace public et mise en
danger de la vie d'autrui toutefois la
solution ne serait pas de désinstaller
ces structures sauvages selon Laurent
Martin de Frémont secrétaire
départementale du syndicat SGP Police ce
qu'il faut surtout c'est œuvrer contre
le trafic de stupéfiants avec plus
d'effectif de police sur le terrain plus
d'enquêteurs et une justice impitoyable
même scénario lors de la fête musulmane
de l'Aïd qui a eu lieu le 28 juin et
aurait été financé par des dealers à
Nice dans le quartier des liserons
gangrené par les trafics ou des affiches
placardés dans les hall d'immeubles et
diffusés sur les réseaux sociaux invitez
les habitants à un buffet grillade
boisson gâteau musique tout gratuit
agrémenté de structures gonflables pour
les enfants ce qui a scandalisé de
nombreux élus dont Eric Ciotti député de
la première circonscription des
Alpes-Maritimes qui a demandé la
destruction du quartier devenu
territoire occupé de la République selon
le député ce n'est pas l'état qui a
abandonné le quartier mais les
islamistes et les dealers qui en ont
pris le contrôle